un code pin
spectacle tenues extravagantes vitesse
une chose est sûre les filles du roller
derby n'ont peur de rien sur leurs
patins à roulettes le contact et souvent
violents les chutes très fréquentes
effectivement il ya un petit côté
déjanté on a plusieurs qui ont des
cheveux de couleur les piercings les
tatouages c'est un sport qui est assez
rock c'est assez décalé moi j'avais
envie de reprendre un sport de combat au
départ et en même temps c'était trop
disciplinés pour moi là il ya de la
musique il ya de la plaisir de la glisse
et il ya le plaisir de se mettre des
coups aussi plus bas après avoir une
bière avec les copies des tribunes cela
pourrait ressembler à une énorme mêlée
pourtant la règle du jeu est très simple
la jammeuse doté d'une étoile sur le
casque doit marquer des points en
dépassant les blocus de l'équipe adverse
prête à tout pour la faire chuter
le roller derby c'est aussi l'occasion
idéale d'oublier à la mode américaine ni
complexe et le quotidien palestinien le
défouloir c'est super important
c'est un sport de filles avant ton donc
ils ont besoin de s'exprimer
voilà sur le trac car la piste
qui après quand elle rentre s'occupent
de leur petite famille on a beaucoup de
mères de famille même si on n'est pas
forcément déjanté à l'extérieur on ne
devient ici par l'esprit par le sport
d'équipé puis c'est un sport américain
donc et à tous tout un peu un show
américain autour et à ça permet aussi
justement nous externalisés pour leur
premier match officiel face aux livres
leur girl des succubes ne l'ont pas
emporté les nul doute qu'elles
continueront encore longtemps de se
battre sur l'euro l'eur